et on arrive à la deuxième grande
question que cette émission je viens de
normandie et c'est jérémy maru qui va
vous la poser alors votre projet de loi
élan arrive dans l'hémicycle dans la
zone à l'assemblée nationale cette
semaine
vous promettez un choc d'offre un choc
de la construction quel en est l'intérêt
alors qu'on a vu en 2017
avec plus de 400 mille logements
construits on était déjà sur des plus
hauts quasiment historique parce que moi
je j'ai une conviction c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya pas une et pas un
problème de logement il ya un très grave
problème de logement en france que
effectivement vous l'avez dit vous avez
raison il ya plus de 400 mille logements
presque 500 mille demandes de permis de
construire qui ont été formulées et fait
l'année dernière c'est autant qu'au
début des années 80 et depuis vous avez
12 millions de français et beaucoup de
familles qui divorcent et donc il y a un
manque très fort de logements en france
et aujourd'hui pour construire des
logements vous avez par exemple pour ne
prendre que celui à un code de la
construction qui fait 2300 pages qui est
plus gros que le code civil ou plus gros
que le code du travail
un code de la construction qui est
totalement prescripteurs qui vous dit
exactement ce que vous devez faire dans
les moindres détails
bref vous avez un système qui est figé
et moi l'un des points dont je suis le
plus fier dans cette loi dont l'examen
débute mercredi
c'est que avec plus de 60 articles on ne
rajoute pas d'obligation au contraire on
libère on fait en sorte que demain il
soit plus facile de construire plus
facile de libérer des terrains plus
facile de laisser libre par à
l'innovation
bref on prend des mesures fortes pour
faire en sorte que demain on construise
plus mieux et moins cher
ce projet de loi il a une gestation
parfois un petit peu douloureuse et
notamment avec les bailleurs sociaux
qu'elles sont comment sortir de cette
logique de rapport de force avec les
bailleurs sociaux quelles sont vos
relations actuellement avec le en fait
les bailleurs sociaux
on a toujours beaucoup travaillé avec
eux y compris lorsque nous avons eu des
moments difficiles que vous avez réduit
les apl et à l'etrat lui pour eux par
une baisse du chiffre d'affaires
évidemment les loyers il s'avère que les
appels sont directement versées aux
bailleurs sociaux effectivement sauf que
toute la discussion ait toute la réforme
que nous portons c'est dire aux
bailleurs sociaux
on va réduire les subventions à la
sortie parce qu'en contrepartie et ça
personne n'en parle parce qu'en
contrepartie on augmente
considérablement les aide à l'entrée
c'est à dire les aides à la construction
parce que c'est quoi la bonne méthode
aujourd'hui en termes d'appui de l'état
pour le secteur de la construction
c'est d'aider là où on construit d'aidé
là on rénove en gros de faire plus
d'eads à la construction plutôt que des
subventions à la sortie c'est en fait
quelque chose qui avait été mis en place
par raymond barre des 40 ans ou raymond
barre à l'époque c'était dire on va
faire plus de subventions à la sortie
que dell à la construction en amont ben
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui cela est une
erreur et donc on inverse la loge à
grimper nous le budget qu'elle consacre
d'état c'est plus de 40 milliards 40
milliards de l'eurocité le thème de la
deuxième question ou de notre sondage
opinionway et 64% des français donc une
forte majorité considère que l'état
consacre assez d'argent pour le logement
mais qu'il est mal utilisé donc soyons
de l'exemple l'exemple que j'ai un
accord est l'exemple que je viens de
vous donner montre qu'on peut faire
mieux on peut faire mieux parce qu'on se
dit que 40 milliards d'euros on peut là
se demander est-ce qu'il faut pas plus
les investir pour justement favoriser la
construction dite ordinaire non le plus
le sénateur et l'ère philippe dallier et
qui est l'une de seine-saint-denis
considère lui que vous allez faire plus
mal on les côtés vous réagissez va
changer le modèle économique du logement
social
on va demander au privé d'intervenir on
va chercher de la rentabilité mais de la
rentabilité dans le logement social
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la rentabilité s'est pas à 30 ans ou à
40 ans sur le modèle actuel ils vont
vouloir de la rentabilité à 10 ans à 15
ans et donc on risque de concentrer les
populations les plus pauvres parce qu'il
va falloir vendre à tout prix des
logements sociaux et donc on va rentrer
dans une mécanique qui n'est plus du
tout celle que nous avons connue qui
n'était peut-être pas parfaite mais qui
avait aussi pour vocation d'assurer un
minimum de mixité sociale et j'ai
vraiment l'impression au travers de la
loi de finances et du textile en est
bien en versant l'éloigner et moi je
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
voilà c'est lourd d'un oui alors il
s'avère qu'on a beaucoup travaillé avec
le sénateur d'allier parce que ce texte
a fait l'objet d'un parcours assez
singulier puisque on a pendant de longs
mois fait ce qu'on appelait une
conférence de consensus
réunis tous les éloges pour les inciter
à l'arrivée gris et on a travaillé avec
eux je suis pas du tout en accord avec
eux ce que vient de dire le sénateur
d'allier le sénateur d'allier ne précise
pas que pour accompagner cette
transformation du logement social qui
est nécessaire il songe est aujourd'hui
qu'il ya près de deux millions de
personnes qui sont en attente d'un
logement social
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on reste dans
le statu quo ont fait rien et on se dit
bas peut-être que dans 20 ans 30 ans 40
ans c'est deux millions de personnes
auront eu une offre de logement social
non on essaye de faire mieux on traîne
on transforme le modèle mais on le fait
de manière totalement responsable c'est
à dire que pour accompagner ces
bailleurs sociaux pour les accompagner
on met en face des investissements qui
sont très importants on leur permet
d'avoir accès à ce qu'on appelle les
financements de la caisse des dépôts de
manière totalement nouvelle
chose qu'il n'avait pas eu jusqu'à
présent on rénove même le livret à qui
est l'une des sources de financement de
ces bailleurs sociaux
bref on fait en sorte de pouvoir les
accompagner dans cette programmation
et que faire des locataires qui
apportait de la mixité sociale
finalement ou en payant un surloyer et
qui continue à occuper leur logement
social et sur le redis il est temps de
partir non moi je pense que la mixité
sociale elle était essentielle et vous
savez le dans le logement social en fait
vous avez énormément de type de
logements qui sont différents donc on
est vraiment très attachés à cette
mixité sociale et notamment on travaille
beaucoup en amont du passage de la loi
avec des députés comme le député
stéphane peu ou françois pupponi pour
justement préserver cette réunion de ce
type en négociation pour l'essentiel 20
% des locataires de l'ism dépasse les
bleus font ni alors que la ressource est
ce qu ils doivent partir
il ya un sujet qui est essentiel c'est
ce qu'on appelle la mobilité au sein du
parc social et la vraie mobilité pendant
des années on s'est dit justement faut
faire partir ces personnes à aller pas
là la vraie mobilité la vraie mobilité
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sous-occupation vous allez beaucoup de
personnes qui pensent que leurs enfants
ont quitté le domicile ont une chambre
vide parfois deux chambres vides et donc
nous ce qu'on fait par la loi ce qu'on
va faire ce qu'ils ont à proposer aux
parlementaires
c'est à dire tous les six ans les
bailleurs sociaux devront proposer je
dis bien proposer à leurs lots mer un
logement qui soit véritablement adapté à
leurs besoins
et pourquoi c'est intéressant parce que
ça veut dire que le f4 le cap pièce où
vous n'avez besoin en fait vous en tant
que locataire qu un deux pièces
vous pouvez leur donner des familles qui
en ont besoin et inversement vous votre
deux pièces vous paierez moins cher que
votre 4 pièces bref tout le monde est
gagnant et moi je pense que le vrai
débat sur la mobilité
il est là il est sur cette mobilité à
l'intérieur des logements sous-occupés
du film alors il ya il ya un autre sujet
qui suscite beaucoup d'inquiétudes et de
critiques
les écologistes entre autres sans s'en
empare c'est la question de la loi
littoral est ce que dans votre loi il ya
un risque finalement de revenir à une
possibilité tout bétonner
regardez c'était là une de var matin
aujourd'hui même nom voilà il ya des
inquiétudes
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire pour
rassurer aujourd'hui mélangez pas l'être
scène je vais très très très claire la
loi littoral c'est 1 1 acquis qu'il ne
faut absolument pas remettre en cause
absolument pas donc je vais être très
claire la loi littoral il faut garder
toute son ambition et je le dis avec
d'autant plus de conviction vous savez
moi je suis ingénieur agronome donc la
fertilisation des sols
je connais et je vois bien tout
l'intérêt et il la loi littoral
bah oui mais après un certain les
écologistes voudraient au créneau et 10
non vous allez me remettre des choses
qui ne sont pas autorisés aujourd'hui
est-ce que qu'est-ce que le débat en
commission la semaine dernière a permis
à permis de faire ce qu'on appelle au
sein d'une zone déjà habité vous avez ce
qu'on appelle des dents creuses c'est à
dire qu'entre deux habitations
vous avez quelque chose qui n'est pas
habité et donc ce que permet la loi
c'est de pouvoir dire au sein de cette
continuer continuité entre ces deux
habitations
quand vous avez une dent creuse il
pourra être demain possible d'y faire
une habitation et voyez vous n'êtes
absolument pas dans une remise en cause
de la loi littoral ni de près ni de loin
et surtout pas sur la bande des 100
mètres savez qui est l'un des principaux
et secondaires de la loi littoral dont
je vais être très rassurant sur ce point
jérémy rassurant aussi pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
on sait que le projet de loi prévoit
d'assouplir les normes en la matière en
créant des logements qu'on appelle
évolutif et là encore les associations
disent attention on remet en cause l
accessibilité mains de la défenseur des
droits le loyer que j'ai reçus en club
que j'ai reçu encore vendredi dernier je
me permets de vous corriger sur un point
il ne s'agit pas de remettre en cause
les normes des personnes en situation de
handicap
je peux vous dire que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé avec elle sur ce
sujet il s'agit de changer un tout petit
peu de logique en disant aujourd'hui
quand vous construisez un immeuble neuf
vous avez 100% de vos logements qui
seront adaptés c'est elle que toutes les
pièces
sont adaptés des personnes à mobilité
réduite en chaise roulante et demain on
va faire des logements dits évolutif
c'est à dire que ces logements seront
vous accompagneront au fur et à mesure
de votre vie dit autrement la salle de
bains qui aujourd'hui peut représenter
quasiment la taille de votre chambre
quand vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir une
salle de bains type adaptés aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
on vous dit ben quand vous n'en avez pas
besoin vous prenez une salle de bains
normal mais le jour où vous en avez
besoin
on a d'ores et déjà conçu l'appartement
pour n'avoir qu'à faire de très faible
transformation pour l'adapter et c'est
juste une logique qui est un tout petit
peu différente qui est de se dire en
rien on diminue les acquis en termes de
normes de personnes en situation de
handicap mais en revanche on fait en
sorte que l'appartement accompagne les
individus évidemment le coût de la
construction c'est pas le coup c'est la
rai
c'est la taille j'insiste beaucoup en
gros un appartement de 65 m² la salle de
bain si aujourd'hui vous dit
tant que vous n'en avez pas besoin vous
l'a laissée à la taille normale ça vous
permet de gagner jusqu'à 20 mètres
carrés alors et donc d'avoir une chambre
plus grande pour vos enfants